البدايه ام عبد الرحمن العصيمي مراسل صباح
العربيه في السعوديه الحديث عن ابرز مكانه
في العام الذي قارب على نهايته
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن يسعد صباحك اهلا صباح
الخير سهام
اييي اقول بانه عام مضى بخيره وشره ونتمنى
انه العام المقبل يكون عام مليء بالاحداث
الجميله
لمنطقتنا وعلمنا العرب والعالم باجمع هذا
العام مر على السعوديه باحداث كثيره
ومختلفه للغايه ابرز الاحداث كان رفع
وزاره الداخليه السعوديه في شهر يونيو
الماضي
لاجراءات الاحتراسيه لكوفيد نايتين فايروس
كرونا والذي كان سبب كبير لسعاده
السعوديين والمقيمين بعد شهور طويله
للاجراءات الاحترازيه المشدده ايضا في 25
يونيو من عام 20 22
كشفه ولي العهد السعودي عن المخططات
والتصاميم الاوليه لمدينه ذا لاين في
اليوم هذه المدينه الحالم وفي شمال غرب
السعوديه ايضا السعوديه قدمت للعالم
النسخه الثانيه من مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر هذه مبادره الضخمه لالغايه تهدف
للزراعه ملايين العشار في منطقتنا ايضا
كان هناك عده فعاليات رياضيه وفنيه موسم
الرياض بدا بحله جديده ومناطق جديده
ابرزها بوليفارد ورد ايضا كان هناك مهرجان
البحر الاحمر للسينما ايضا كان هناك موسم
الدرعيه بطوله
التنس الدوليه ايضا بطوله الجولف الدوليه
وغيرها من الفعاليات الفنيه لحفلات
الموسيقيه مدى البيست الذي شهد حضور اشهر
الدجاج العالميين ايضا ابرز الحدث المهم
هو فوز المنتخب السعودي على نظيره
الارجنتيني في نسخه كاس العالم في قطر
والج الشهيره التي اصبحت ايقونه لكاس
العالم ورز ميسي
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن شكرا لك في اخر طله
لك في صباح العربيه هذه السنه شكرا لك
نورتنا السنه كلها عبد الرحمن نذهب الى
روسيا كيف كانت في عام 20 22 ز
ميلنا صباح العربيه سيطلعنا من هناك على
روسيا المتجمده حراريا ولكن احداثها ساخنه
دوما ماذا لديك عبد الجواد قبل ان تذهب
الى المنزل لانه برد كثير واضح
صباح الخير نادين وصباح الخير لسهام وصباح
الخير لصباحه العربيه كل عام وانتم بخير
قد لا يكون عام 2002 و20 هو الافضل
بالنسبه للحياه في روسيا خلال هذه الفتره
باعتبار ان موسكو تدخل صراعا من العيار
الثقيل مع الغرب قد يكون الاكبر لها عبر
التاريخ لكن رغم السوداويه الوضع الا ان
عجله دوران الحياه في روسيا وفي موسكو ما
زالت مستمره معظم الاحداث التي كانت مقرره
خلال عام 2022 تمت بالكامل الاحتفالات
بدءا من راس السنه اعياد لكريسماس عيد
النصر عيد المراه معظم همم يعني اوقات
السنه كانت تعيش اوقات واحتفالات كما هو
مقرر الوضع الثقافي وضع المسارح وضع
الموسيقى الحفلات الوضع الرياضي طبعا رغم
العقوبات الكبيره التي قالت كافه ارجاء
المشاركه على الصعيد الدولي الا ان
الاحداث الداخليه في روسيا ما زالت قائمه
حتى ان فصل الشتاء كما تشاهدين دين قد جاء
مبكرا هذا العام هذه هي ثلوج موسكو يعني
التي تصلوا عاده بهذه الكميات في شهر مارس
او في شهر يعني ابريل القادم الا انها
اليوم في شهر ديسمبر تملا طبعا اراضي
وضاحات وحدائق وشوارع مدينه موسكو الوضع
مستقر نوعا ما في ظل طبعا الاخبار العاجله
التي نسمعها على مدار الساعه مع الازمه
الاوكرانيه هناك لكن طبعا مع سوداويه
الموضوع كما تحدث الشعب الروسي ما زال
مؤمنا بالحياه مؤمنا بالسلام مؤمنا بالحب
يحاول ايصال رساله السلام انا اتحدث عن
الشعب بشكل عام عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الى الشعب الاوكراني الذي
يعتبره شقيقا طبعا خلال 20022 تحدثنا الى
مئات الاشخاص في روسيا حول وضع الشعب
الاوكراني معظمهم يقولون بان الشعب
الاوكراني هو الشعب الشقيق الاول لروسيا
ولا هم تاريخ عريق يربط البلدين على مدار
100.000 السنين تحياتي لكم ولجميع افراد
صباح العربيه ولمخرجون الرائع ولجميع يعني
الاشخاص المجهولون خلف كوادر الكاميرات كل
التحيات
صباح العربيه يارينا اهلا بك تغطيتك خلال
كل هذه السنه كانت مميزه
وليثك الجميله حدثنا عن احداث لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
نعم يودعوا لبنان عمل مليء بالاخفاقات على
كافه الاصعد الاجتماعي والسياسيه والماليه
وربما يدخل يعني بالعام 2023 دون رئيسا
للجمهوريه دون حكومه وفضل انهيار مستمر
لليره ولكن مع ذلك بكثير من الامل هذا
الامل الذي انعكس روما ازمه الكهرباء
المستمره اضواء وزينه في كافه المناطق
اللبنانيه ان اليوم على ضفاف بحيره النشعي
حيث يعني تعدوا مركز لانشطه ثقافيه تنشروا
كثيرا من الفرح في ابناء هذه المنطقه هنا
تقوم وسط ضفاف هذه البحيره كما ترون خلف
شجره ميلاديه من عبوات البلاستيكيه كثيره
تحمل توقيع لبنانيه ادخلت لبنان الى
موسوعه جينيس همم عده مرات وفيها يعني
رساله الى اهميه همم الى اطفاء الفرحه
اولا واهميه التشجيع على اعاده التدوير
وليس بعيدا من هنا وعلى طول الخط الساحلي
من من الشمال الى بيروت مرورا بشكه
والبترون وجبال وجونه وصولا الى وصفه
المدينه اسواق الميلاديه والاضواء وزينه
ولو بمبادرات خاصه في في معظم الاحيان الا
ان وصل عاصمه كان لافتا هذا العام وصل
العاصمه الذي تحول الى مكان مهجور بعد
انفجار الرابع من اب عاد اليه الكثير من
رونقه عاد مقصدا لكثير من السياح ولكثير
من المغتربين الذين يعول عليهم لبنان
انعاشيه اقتصاديا وضخ العمله الصعبه هؤلاء
المغتربون الذين يعني قصدوا لبنان
للمعايده مع اهلهم ول- اا دعم ابنائهم
وصله كل الازمات الكثيره التي يعيشها
لبنان هذه الازمات التي افرزت اشكالا
كبيره من التعاضد الاجتماعي الذي يتميز
فيه لبنان فليس من فتره قليله مثلا اقيم
ماراثون ميلادي رقد فيه اكثر من 500 شخص
دائما مركز همم سرطان الاطفال في لبنان
على على ازمه مستمر بالدواء وبحليب
الاطفال وبكل ذلك ولكن همم يبقى على موعد
همم كبير بامل افضل المحاولات اللي انعاش
هذا البلد ولو الى حين
شكرا جزيلا دائما ريندوي مستمرون معكم في
هذه الرحله حول العالم مع مراسل العربيه
ولا يمكن لنا ان نمر ونعبر عن الاردن بدون
ان نسلم على سهى جميل من هناك مراسله صباح
العربيه سهى انت علم من اعلام الاردن
الاعلامي في التقارير وفي الظهور وفي
الافكار التي اضحكتينا بها طوال لهذا
العام الكلمه لكي
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير نادين صباح الخير سهام بدايه
شكرا نادين على هذا الكلام على الصعيد
الشخصي بدايه اردنيه في يوم من الايام في
هذا العام الذي سيمضي التقيت بك نادين كان
من اجمل الايام صراحه وبكل امانه هذه
الشخصيه نادين خماش اتمنى الجميع ان يعرف
نادين على حقيقتها الجميله هذا بالنسبه لي
كانت من اجمل الايام اما بالنسبه
للاردنيين اجمالا نرد على الاردنيين او
يرجع الاردنيون هذا العام بين الحزن
والفرح بين الماساه وبين الامل كان هناك
انهيار لعماره في منطقه الويبده ولكن
اخراج الطفله ملاك من تحت الانقاض بعد
يومين كان خبرا سرا لجميع الاردنيين الذين
انتظروا هذا الخبر في ظل الظروف الصعبه
التي يمر بها همم كان هناك خبر ايضا ادراج
المنسف كاكله تاريخيه واكله شعبيه وهويه
اردنيه على قائمه التراث العالمي اليونسكو
هذا يعزز طبعا هذا الطبق عالميه خاصه وان
الاردنيون يستخدونا فيه به جميع الولائم
والعزائم وهو هو هويه تعرف عنهم اضافه الى
اختيار الاردن همم الدوله الاكثر رومانسيه
للسياحه في الشرق الاوسط لعام 2022 وهذا
بالنسبه للاردنيين طبعا خبر جميل جدا على
الصعيد السياحي خاصه وانه رافض وهم
للاقتصاد وغيرها من الاخبار السعيده التي
مرت ولكن للاسف كانت الاخبار المتتاليه
مؤخرا منها الاعتصامات على ارتفاع اسعار
المشتقات النفطيه وما حدث مع اشتباك من
رجال الامن وخساره اربعه منهم ودعنا هذا
العام بهذه الاخبار السيئه ولكن كل ما
يتمناه الاردنيون هو عكس ما حدث معهم في
عام
2-22 ان يحدث هناك يعني
الاخبار تيملاها الامل همم الانتعاش
الاقتصادي الانعاش السياحي والانتعاش على
الصعيد الشخصي
اكيد وهذا ما نتمناه بكل الاصعده لجميع
الدول ولنك افراد ايضا شكرا سهى جميل
مراسله صباح العربيه من عمان وللحديث اب
عن ابرز الاحداث هذه المره في بريطانيا
لعام 2022 تنضم الينا من لندن زميله عروب
عبد الحق مراسله صباح العربيه عروبي يسعد
صباحك كنت معنا طيره هذه السنه لتغطيه
احداث لندن من استقاله بوليس جونسون الى
وفاه الملكه اليك الكلمات في اخر اطلاله
هذه السلامه مع صباح العرب
صباح الخير نادين بالفعل يعني هذا العام
على بريطانيا التي يعني قد تكون من اكثر
الدول التي شهدت ازمات سياسيه وتقلبات هذا
العام سواء من الناحيه السياسيه او من
ناحيه العائله الملكيه ويبدو ان
الاضطرابات هي ستكون العنوان الاكبر
للحكومه التي تواجه الحكومه في عام 2023
ابتاه من الجانب السياسي طبعا هو اقل ما
يوصف بان الوضع السياسي هنا في بريطانيا
فقط في اقل من شهرين هذا العام همم بدات
هذه الفوضى ربما في يوليو تحديدا عندما
استقال رئيس الوزراء الصادق بورجونسون على
خلفيه تراكم ازمات وقضاء حكايه قد مر بها
مثل همم
فضائح همم يعني تحرش صاله بعض المقربين
همم
ااا رئاسه الحكومه من بعد لتكون لذلك ثالث
امراه تقود بريطانيا ولكنها اقصرهم مده
حكم يعني بعد 45 يوم فقد استقالت رئيسه
الوزراء بعد همم يعني سمي في كلاش اوف
كلانس
بانها كارثه من الناحيه الاقتصاديه باقاله
وزير الماليه واخذه المقربين لها وانتهى
في استقالتها ايضا ليتسلم مع بعض في سباق
سريع لحزب المحافظ وهو الذي يبدو بانه
مواجهه اكبر تحدياته همم
من خلال الاضرابات التي تتسارع وحدتها
خلال الاسابيع والشهور الماضيه عشرات
الاضرابات شهدتها قطاعات مختلفه في
بريطانيا هذا الشهر وتحديد المزيد من
الاضرابات في بدايه العام المخرج هو في
قطاع الصحه في البريد في قطاع السكك
الحديديه وغيرها اما من ناحيه العائله
الملكيه فيبدوا بانها ايضا شهدت العديد من
التقلبات والاحداث التاريخيه همم العائله
الملكيه شهدت اول يوبيل 30 لها عندما
احتفلت الملكه اليزابيث الرحله بمروج 78
عام على تواليها العرش البريطاني بعد
ثلاثه اشهر رحله الملكه اليزابيث في
سبتمبر من عام 2022 وفي مقتل يعني طبعا
مهيب ل همم الملكه الراحله طبعا
الذي يعني فجر قنبله من العيار الثقيل
بالنسبه للعائله الملكيه التي ستواجه هذا
التحدي من الناحيه الاسماك العائليه العام
المقبل نعود اليك اليك شكرا
نذهب الان الى امريكا وابرز الاحداث لعام
20 22 من واشنطن الزميله ريتا سليمان
مراسله صباح العربيه ريتا يسعد هالصباح
اولا واسمحي لي انا اسواق بالكلام قبل ما
تحكي لنا اي شغله عن احداث امريكا اكثر
شخص حصل معه تغيرات في 20 22 غادرتينا
غادرتينا لامريكا وانتقالتي بقيتي في نفس
المجال ونفس المكان بس من مذيعه في
الاستديو الى مراسله واثبتنا نجاحك وتميزت
اكثر فاكثر ريتا هذا اللي لي اقوله كل عام
وانت بالف خير ولك دائما
له طعم مختلف تماما من صباحاتنا
الميك اب برو
ستوديوس همم لا هون هلا همم عبر زوم سنه
2022 كانت طالع سنه تحديات همم على
المستوى الشخصي وعلى المستوى العملي ايضا
وعلى همم ايضا للولايات المتحده همم ايضا
ان كان في على المستوى الشركات شركه ابل
وصلت قيمتها الى حد ثلاثه مليون دولار
وهذا امر كبير جدا هنا في الولايات
المتحده هذه اعلى نسبه تصل اليها شركه
امريكيه في التاريخ همم ايضا على المستوى
الفني همم لا ننسى الصفحه الشهيره التي
وجهها
في الاسكارس
همم قبل دقائق قليله من الحصول على جائزه
افضل ممثل طبعا طبعا مدافع عن المنظمين
لحرمانه من الحدود
10 سنوات ايضا على المستوى الفنيه همم
المحاكمه الشهيره بين امبير
التشهير المحكمه اتهمت همم
الزوجين السابقين بتهم التشهير المتبادله
هذه المحاكمه استمرت منذ الحديث عشر من
ابريل حتى الاول من يونيو وانتهت في الحكم
على لصالح رجال داب ايضا همم على المستوى
القانوني الغث- محكمه امريكيه العليا الحق
الدستوري للمراه في الاجهاض وهذا امر
في الولايات المتحده فقدت حوالي 66 مليون
امراه في سن الانجاب الحق القانوني في
الاشهار الذي كان قانون قانونيا في اكثر
من 50 همم
ولايه ولمده 50 عام همم ايضا انصقل الى
المجال الفضائي والتحديات الاولى مع ظهور
المجموعه الاولى من الصور كامله الالوان
من ثلاث جيمس الفضائي للنجوم ومجرات بعيده
وبدقه عاليه لم يسبق لنا او لاي انسان
النظر اليها بهذه التفاصيل صحيا ايضا كان
هناك تسجيل خرق كبير في القطاع الصحي
خصوصا مع مرض الالزايمير اكتشاف راكنه
بشكل فعال من ابطاء تقدم هذا المرض لا
يمكن ان ننسى المجال التقني ووسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي التي اخذت حيز كبير من
الاخبار هنا في
السابع والعشرين من اكتوبر ايضا استحوا
على تويتر رسميا وبدات حكم التعبير بيطارد
عدد كبير من الموظفين وكبار المدراء
التنفيذيين وايضا باليوم التالي في الثمن
والعشرين من اكتوبر شاهدنا نهايه عهد
الازدهار همم بالقطاع التكنولوجيا طبعا
هذا كان باختصار مجمل الاحداث وطبعا نتمنى
للجميع عام جديد مليء بالخير والصحه اليكم
احنا بنشكرك جزيل الشكر بنقول لك تصبحي
على خير
شكرا لانني لا تونس الحديث عن ابرز
الاحداث لعام 2022 تنضم الينا من تونس
لملتنا الجميله دائما احلام العبدلي احلام
يسعد صباحك من المشاركه المشرفه لتونس في
المونديال الى دخولها العالميه في التنس
حدثينا اكثر عن ابرز احداث تونس
صباح النور على جميلته مقدمات سبحا
العربيه وعلى جميع المشاهدين من هنا من
تونس والشمس لما تظهر بعد لم يكن عمل
الناس
شكرا شكرا نوركم انتم اللي تاغي وانا على
الصعيد الشخصي خال بس اقول ملاحظه انه
اعتبر من اجمل الاشياء اللي سالتني في هذا
السنه انه انا انضميت لفريق صلاح العربيه
هذا الفريق الجميل والرائع تونس لم تكن
سنه سهله عليها كبقيه الدول لكن سوف نكون
ايجابيين باعتبار ونحن نبحث عن الاشياء
الايجابيه ونتمنى ان يكون عام جديد مليء
بالايجابيه والفرح والسعاده المونديال
اللي هو ابرز
السنه ومشاركه المنتخب الوطني التونسي في
المونديال وفوزه على بطل العالم فرنسا هذا
الفوز الذي جعل المنتخب والتوانسه نوعا ما
ينسونا مراره الاخفاق في المرور الى الدور
الموالي هذه الحلم الذي كان يراود
التونسيين وكان سيخفف عليهم كما قلنا
وتاتا العاب اليوم والحياه اليوميه كانت
سنه تربعت فيها على قلوب التونسيين وزيره
السعاده التونسيه اونس جابر بطله التنس
التونسيه التي عرفت صحتي ويمبلدو امجيد
انس جابر وكذلك عرف العالم من هي اول
عربيه واول افريقيه وصلت الى هذه البطولات
العالميه اونز جابر التي اثرت قلوب
الملايين وحققت انجازات تاريخيه واصبحت
هنا في تونس وفي دول اخرى اصبحت قدوه في
هذه الرياضه التي تعتبر ربما الرياضه
كسرت هذه القاعده تلك الفتاه القادمه من
عائله متوسطه ومن المصعد الاجتماعي
التونسي حققت انجازات وانجازات كبيره جدا
ومن هنا نحن نحيي البطل العظيمه اونس جابر
كذلك تونس كانت على موعد مع انجاز اخر مهم
ومهم جدا باعتبار انا التونسيين همم
ينتبهون ويعتنون جدا بالاكل وكذلك هناك
مقاوم اساسي في الاكل التونسي الذي هو
لهريسه او ما يعبر عنه في الشرع بالشطه
الهريسه تدخل العالميه هذه في هذه السنه
اواخر ادي سنه من اوسع ابوابها من خلال
ادراج هذا من التراث العالمي اللامادي
ليونسكو التونسيون متعلقون جدا بهذا
المكون في المطبخ التونسي هو احد ابرز
مكونات الاطباق التونسيه خاصه الاطباق
منها الحاره ونحن نتحدث عن فصل الشتاء
تقريبا يوميا حتى ينسى يتسلحون هذا المكون
في اطباقهم الشعبيه من اجل مواجهه هذا
الصقيع الذي ينزل علينا الان وهو احلام يا
احلام نتمنى ان تتحقق معك كل الاحلام من
تونس احلام عشرين 22 شكرا لك نبقى مع سمر
بشوات وسنرى مصر بعيون المصريه سمر كيف
كانت في 20 22 الصعيد البلد
ثانيا
صباح الخير يا نادين صباح الخير يا سهام
وكل سنه وانتم طيبين والامه العربيه كلها
بخير يا رب على سعيد الشخصي الحمد لله
كانت سنه جميله كانت سنه حلوه تحققت فيها
حاجات حلوه وعلى الصعيد العام بقى في مصر
مصر دائما جميله ومليانه بالاحداث الفنيه
والثقافيه مصر بلد حيه لما تمشي في الشارع
الناس كلها عندها حكايات تقولها
واحداث يمكن انا هبتدي انا اخترت المكان
ده هنا احنا هنا في ممشى اهل مصر لان ده
كان اكبر مشروع سياحي اتعمل على كورنيش
النيل اا في القاهره بطول هو يعني المرحله
الاولى اللي تم افتتاحها كانت 1,800 متر
بس هيمتد بطول خمسه كيلو مترات همم ده في
مطاعم وفي مرسى يخوت ومسرح
وبيستضيف العديد من الفعاليات الثقافيه
والفنيه همم
هننتقل الناحيه الثانيه دي كان من اهم
الاحداث اللي تمت برده همم في مصر كان
الشهر الماضي همم مؤتمر المناخ الكوب 20
همم في شرم الشيخ بحضور اكثر من 60 شخصيه
من زعماء ومسؤولين وخبراء ونسعديين همم
اهم طبعا ال- ال- المحاور كانت على موضوع
المناخ والبيئه وكيف نحافظ على البيئه
واهم تحدي كان بيتكلموا عنه طبعا ال- اا
زياده الحراره او ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض
وكيف نتعامل مع هذا صاحب المؤتمر ده
الحقيقه طول السنه كان مشاريع كثيره همم
بتدعم ال- ال- ال- البيئه الخضراء وترشيد
المياه وكلها حاجات متعلقه بالبيئه همم
المناطق الاثريه في مصر شاهدت برده
فعاليات مهمه السنه دي ومختلفه يعني عندنا
مثلا همم لاول مره بيتعمل عرضين للازياء
العالميه في مناطق اثريه منها كان لسه
قريب عرض كريستين جورج همم بس عند
الاهرامات وكان عرض همم استيفان ريتشي ف
معبد حتشبسوت في الاقصر همم ومن اهم
الاحداث الاثريه ايضا كان السنه دي مرور
100 عام على افتتاح مقبره توت عنخ امون
اللي اكتشفها
البريطاني هاورد كارتر وم- وعلى سعيد
السينمائي اخر حاجه همم اهم حاجه تولع مره
اخرى الفنان حسين فهمي مهرجان القاهره
السينمائي وتم تاجيل مهرجان الجونه لحين
اشعار اخر
كل سنه وانتم طيبين كل سنه وانت طيب ومن
قلبي قريب من القاهره سمر بشوات الممثله
صباح العربيه شكرا لك يعني فعلا مين اللي
جاي مستر حجازي اليك جايين
ههه صباح الخير ههه
انت مستنيه دورك من الصبح صباح الخير انا
مستنيه الدور ده ايوه من الصبح وانا
مستنياك اصغر مراسله في صباح العربيه
واصغر واحده فينا
يعني الحمد لله
بالنسبه لي ههه
هو الحمد لله ان انا اصغر واحده علشان
امشي بدري ههه بقى
اتفضلي اتفضلي وانت عينه يا ندى الوقت ضيق
السنه كانت سنه مثيره للجدل جدا يمكن احنا
كان عندنا احداث كثير في مصر كرويا
متوفقناش في كاس امم افريقيا ولا تاهلها
لكاس العالم
والصدفه في المبارتين ان احنا خسرنا قدام
السنغال بدربات الجزاء بس ده ما منعش
وجودنا في كاس العالم بقوه لان الكوره كاس
العالم كانت صناعه مصريه وكمان كان في
مشاركه فنيه من فرح الدباني ويجز في حفله
الافتتاح وطبعا يعني وجودهم اضاف يعني
طابع كده خاص جدا للحفل اا على الصعيد
كمان الفني كان في احداث كثير مثيره للجدل
على صعايده العلاقات زي ما انتم قلتم من
شويه علاقه حسام وشيرين وعلاقه من عرفه
وكمان الدرس كود اللي احنا شفناه الزاني
في مهرجان القاهره وقسم الناس بين مؤيد
ومعارض للاسف هو ده انا فنانين كتير زي
مها ابو عوف هشام سليم سمير صبري ودعنا
كمان همم المحامي الكبير فريده الديب اللي
قبل ما يتوفى على طول كان متصدر همم يعني
كثير من عناوين الاخبار بعد اعلان ان هو
همم هيدافع عن قاتل نيره اشرف وطبعا دي اا
نوع من الجرائم احنا بنتمنى نودعه في 20
23 هو وكل الجرائم تماما
اا احنا يمكن بلد فيها احداث كتير وتردات
كثير بس احنا ما شفناش السنه دي اطول من
التراند بتاع عامل النظافه اللي اتطرد من
محل الكشري يعني اعتقد ان ده التريند اللي
مكمل معنا ل23 وان شاء الله يعني السنه
الجديده هاغطي معكم اخبار اسعد ومغامرات
اكتر واشوفكم دائما بخير كل عام وانت بالف
خير يا ندى من القاهره ندى حجازي لان
الحديث ابرز الاحداث في العراق
زينب اهلا بك من العواصف الترابيه الى كاس
خليجي 25 والشعار سنه اكو سؤال صبايا
ههه
[ضحك]
صباح الخير صبايا طبعا كل عام وانتم بخير
مقدما واتمنى لكم انها تحققوني المزيد من
النجاحات في السنه القادمه اييه بالنسبه
ليا وعلى سعيد الشخص يعني سعيده جدا
لانضمام لكادر صباح العربيه
خلاص خلاص اليوم فش تواصل كملي كملي
معناتها نحن دائما متجددين تمام
[موسيقى]
اكيد من العواصف الترابيه والتغيرات
البيئيه والمناخيه ايضا شهدت الكثير من
المناطق في العراق جفاف لكن هذا الجفاف
همم
نتحدث عنه من الجانب الايجابي انه كان
هناك دعم كبير من السائحين الاجانب والعرب
الذين زاروا العراق خلال هذه الفتره
ودعموا المناطق المعرضه للجفاف مثل
الاهوار اطلقها هاشتاج تصدر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي انقذوا الاهوار من الجفاف هذا
الدعم بحد ذاته كان ايجابي بالنسبه
للعراقيين ايضا همم
زار العراق اكثر من 200 فنان مسرح عربي
عربي خلال فعاليات مهرجان المسرح الدولي
الثالث
وقدم العراق حوالي 19 عمل مسرح هذا ما يدل
على ان المسرح في العراق ينبض الحياه
اضافه الى هذا ان العراق صدر العديد من
الكتب والثقافه والادب من خلال المثقفين
والكتاب العراقيين بيطلع لك دول نشر
العراقيه وهذا ما لحقناه في فعاليات معرض
العراق الدولي للكتاب
واختتم العراق عامه 2022
وسيلينطلق ايضا في عام 2023 بفعاليه كاس
الخليج بدورته الخامسه والعشرين التي
ستقام في البصره وهذا هذه فعاليه تعد مهمه
جدا بالعراق لانفتاح
على دول الخليج مره اخرى وعودتها
الدول العربيه كل عام وانت بالف خير زينب